so let's let's jump to this next story
we have this from cnet gas prices are at
record highs here's why they won't drop
anytime soon okay sure
13 states a gallon of regular is
averaging more than five bucks
in mendocino california 960 a gallon
they say 13 states california they say
is over five bucks california is
averaging 6.37 a gallon right now the
national average is 4.92
this number is apocalyptic in politics
yeah people
that you i guarantee you you go to the
you go to a random place working class
place and you ask them anything about
pelosi the supreme court and they're
gonna say i don't know i don't know i
don't know i can't afford gas yeah how
am i supposed to get to work and it's
it's june so we're only going up from
here i mean that's the thing like has
gas ever gone down in the summer and
right now the summer driving months are
when it goes nuts peak driving season
we're entering those yes we're entering
i i eight dollars an average they're
saying my kids are sick of i drive
you know back and forth whatever and i
just look at i'm like i have never seen
gas above
350 i mean is that that's right right
like never above 350.
the record was four or something under
i've never seen it though because it's
always in places like california
i've never seen it
oh yeah what was the national average
during the bush years it would be
important it did hit as high as four
bucks but
i think it was four in chicago but
national average was probably been 350 i
don't remember it ever over 350. but now
i mean i drove i drive by something 520
today cnn's saying it's going to be
20 6.20 per gallon by august i think
it's gonna be higher i think it's gonna
be higher i keep on doing this thing i'm
never a person who lets my tank go past
half
and i keep on sort of like pushing it
like well maybe a gas will down tomorrow
maybe it'll go down tomorrow and it just
keeps on going up i i i would not be
surprised if we hit seven or eight yeah
come on yes buying gas has become more
like the stock market yo
three
325 was the highest under george w bush
yeah see that i did on average and then
368 under obama
and then under trump the average was
280 highest at its highest lowest was
like a dollar fifty yes i remember it
was under two and i was like judging
when i was filling up my tank i have a
minivan and it was costing like 35 to
fill the minivan now it's 87. to be fair
under bush in his first few years it was
a dollar 40 on average yeah decently and
then it started skyrocketing towards the
end and then under obama so
it's funny because people keep pointing
out that they show these images of four
dollars a gallon gas under bush and
they're like i remember when gas was
this high why are you blaming biden no
and i'm like yo that those weren't the
average prices you're looking at
california and new york there's that one
gas station in dc on the hill that's
next to the heritage foundation yeah and
everyone always takes pictures in front
of that one it's like well that's not
actually the average but i drove past i
was driving my kid into rockville
maryland today and i passed 5 20.
wow that's here i was getting a haircut
and as i'm getting a haircut
people in this area they're like do you
see the gas prices do you see what they
are so even even local people are
talking about how there's one store
that's offering uh you know 30 percent
off a gallon if you buy a carton of
cigarettes
we got to go to this store we've got to
smoke it right at the gas i mean this
these are conversations that are
happening with average people with
normal people that are getting
politically involved because they were
thrown into a mess which sadly you know
a lot of ignorance has led to this
because we saw the warning signs from a
very long time ago ever since 2008 the
signs were there but there was a warning
sign in joe biden talking about climate
change yeah so again i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna make a moral statement on
climate change but joe biden and
democrats have long said we need exactly
this
yeah they want high gas prices so people
don't drive so there's less carbon
emissions joe biden shut down keystone
he banned uh fracking on on public lands
he shut down various oil and gas leases
josh hawley has the list better than me
yeah he took action specifically over
climate and environmental issues and
that is a major contributor to why you
are paying so much of the gas pump yeah
he called it no no it's working i looked
into getting a hybrid i i was like we
can't we can't keep on doing this but
the problem is they keep on talking
about like this is the solution but it's
not because the cars aren't available
and they're not i i can't drive in a
hybrid i have five kids we need more
space than that it's not well so
the the end result of all of this look
if you if you follow after the
environmental narrative it is going to
be suffering yeah they that that's it
that's the only way in in france they
put a petrol tax result on you know a
tax on the fuel resulted in what 18
months of rioting
because it's it's simple when they come
out and say you've got to cut back
they're saying it's going to get really
it's going to get a lot worse for you
your standards will be
they're saying you are the carbon that
they want to get rid of and and again we
were talking about this yesterday biden
is talking about these high gas prices
being a quote incredible transition he
was talking about how he wants to build
back better how he wants to set up more
green policies as we're literally
importing oil from saudi arabia that all
of that in the name of green policies
instead of domestic energy production
and then there's these then there's
these politicians like this democratic
senator came out what's bragging how the
gas prices don't matter to her because
she has an electric vehicle so
let's think about what happens in in in
november
gas prices are going to hit a peak in
august yeah a couple months beforehand i
don't think there's a single word a
democrat could say at that point that's
it yeah they're going to put out all the
ads in the world and i wouldn't be
surprised if they actually if we have
like a record i'm i don't mean this
literally but i'm saying i would not be
surprised if there's a record low spend
from democrats because they're like just
just going to write it off don't waste
the money yeah save it for 2024. you
would think that they would have their
messaging a little better right like
they're talking about gun control
they're talking about abortion and
they're they're talking about like well
i don't care about guest persons because
i haven't this is a great transition
we're building back better this is
awesome this is great for the
environment robust recovery yeah but if
the jobs report is good therefore all of
your suffering doesn't matter because
someone got a job inflation is
transportation it's temporary oh it's
actually good for you yeah it's crazy
it's absolutely insane the talking
points that they're releasing i'd call
it gaslighting if it wasn't so insane
it's like it's it's but that's the
definition though it's just crazy i
liken it to that family guy joke where
peter's in an elevator with one other
guy and he farts and then says it was
you
like that's what they're doing they're
saying the economy is better than ever
and you're like bro i'm pumping my gas
right now right here yeah i'm standing
here
so i think when they say the best
pulling in 80 years
when you consider the fact that the
polling has been skewed by what like
seven points
nah it's gonna be
i i you know people are calling it a red
wave right there's gonna be a gop red
wave and then some people started saying
wow look at the polls it's gonna be a
tsunami i'm like no it's gonna be a
great flood and democrats better start
building that so what what is the senate
numbers do you know what the senate
numbers are looking like um i think it's
going to be like a couple seats it's
like republicans might have
52 or 53 okay all right because then
that's that's who knows man look it's
we're five months out that's an eternity
and we got to speculate on what's going
to happen in august then speculate
what's going to happen in october but
i'll add this
we don't have any fertilizer because of
the war with between ukraine and russia
that severely limited our our resources
there
so they predicted this months ago back
in february march the fall harvest is
going to be brutal it's going to be down
40 we're going to see food costs
skyrocket there's going to be a shortage
of diesel meaning you're not going to
have the food and if it does come i
gotta tell everybody right now if you
don't have emergency supplies or
whatever it sounds like you might be
fighting over the last can of beans with
agnes in the parking lot at a walmart
maybe that's a little too much though
but i'll tell you this you're certainly
gonna be fighting over toilet paper
because that already happened yeah yeah
it's not crazy because we all just went
through it or baby formula i know you
know it part of me is like oh man to say
you're going to be fighting over bean
sounds crazy
people are already there's videos of
people fighting over baby formula yeah
because it's life and death that's the
problem with baby formula as opposed to
almost any other product on the market
it is not replaceable you can't just
give a baby who's like three months old
whole milk and be like good luck to you
and you can but what about nesquik if
you mix it in that's good right probably
not no wouldn't do it
what about the gm uh gmo lab mate bill
gates milk that he's uh developing and
making on very uh coincidentally as well
you can test it on goats but
coincidentally look if you're an
investor and you see the news who would
not be investing in future materials
metamaterials whatever you can do like
fake meat graphene for instance
i got
graphene graphene yeah yeah what is that
it's a hexagonally latticed monoatomic
carbon it's like a layer of carbon a
flat layer of atomic carbon and it's um
hexagonal so it's like it looks like a
honeycomb okay it meant here it's
actually some right here it's a powder
black powder it's pure carbohydrate did
i just open a pandora's yes
but let's let's let's layers like a 21st
century steel it's an incredible
building material with electric sorry
i'll get into it later it's drink
they're they're they're they use it for
making better batteries it's a very
powerful one touch screen wall
it's going to be revolutionary my my
point here is when you're watching the
collapse in this way you're going to be
investing in food farmland um chickens
raw materials chickens bill gates is
buying farmland he's making fake meat
and he's making fake breast milk how
convenient that that aligns perfectly
with his agenda i mean he's a
businessman he wants to invest in what
he needs to invest in it makes sense
doesn't it good he's definitely uh
cornered the market to say the least i
could say a lot more about this but but
from everything that i'm seeing i think
in the future there's going to be a lot
more economic instability i think that's
that's without a doubt definitely
happening here in the united states i
think we're going to be seeing more
limited uh
you know supplies
you know random items that are not going
to be available i don't think it's going
to be as bad as it will be in places
like in africa in the middle east which
are definitely expected to deal with the
full brunt of this larger geopolitical
proxy war that's happening inside of
ukraine especially with the wheat and
the fertilizer crisis which will hit
them the richer countries will be able
to afford a lot of the wheat a lot of
the food they will be importing at other
countries that are poor in the middle
east and africa they're going to be
facing some significant problems that
is going to be overwhelming thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you